guten tag mein name ist manuel und
diejenigen die mich kennen die wissen
wahrscheinlich dass ich ein minimalist
in mich macht es glücklich nicht so
viele dinge zu besitzen
und heute bin ich in berlin
friedrichshain um mal zu schauen ob die
leute hier genauso ticken tischfußball
[Musik]
willst du mit minimal ist als das ist
also ein minimalist ist jemand der nur
ganz wenig besitzt weil er nicht so viel
besitzen will auseinander worten hast du
ganz viel spielzeug oder nur ganz wenig
und das ist auch gut oder sagst du es
eigentlich so viel du auf tour und ist
einer zuviel würdest du gerne weniger
spielzeuge besitzen
warum weinst du da mal auszumisten und
ein bisschen spielt durch zu verschenken
oder verkaufen
sie machte das hier so mit einer kiste
würde waren rein womit ich zwei spiele
und dann was passiert mit ihrem anwalt
so auch nicht verschwindet einfach mag
ist seit ihrem minimales ein
entschlossenes nein bitte begründen ist
ich glaube ich habe von allem wird hier
viele durch auf jede spur
sollte sich minimalistisch und machte
das spaß
die ganzen sachen zu besitzen oder sagst
du eigentlich wärst du lieber
minimalisten
gute frage
bücher und fuhr einfach spaß verändern
gegen wäre ich vielleicht gern
minimalistischer für mich auch schon
weil es einfach gemütliche zu meiner
wohnung kommt und da an riesen
bücherregale schuhe kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen erklären warum das schön
ist und man kann dies sei ja das ist
vielleicht so ein kleines für samels
hebe aber aber im leben ist wenn man
brauche ich so viele sachen besitzen
weil man nichts mehr 200 jahre mann
nicht 100 jahre auch versucht gar nicht
mit ins grab nehmen
warum genau warum so ich habe kein geld
zur verfügung deswegen habe ich die
möglichkeit mit großer verkaufen und
dementsprechend wenig sehr
minimalistische design aus der not
geboren
wärst du denn wenn du jetzt morgenluft
wir finden würde gewinnen gewöhnt
wie sagt man er fragt mich ich hab nicht
viel aus weil ich für habe also ich
nicht gebrauchen
und dann sollte quasi automatisch
minimalisten weil die katzen die lego
steine entfernt
wenn du morgen im lotto gewinnen wirst
du dann immer noch minimal ist
wahrscheinlich erstmal nicht
wahrscheinlich würde ich auch erst mal
ausklinken und dafür dass wir als erstes
kaufen als allererstes eine schöne
gitarre was man seiner was ist eine
traum gefangen akustische und
elektrische sein
eine schöne gibson les paul
ich bin minimalist eigentlich immer
schon als kind hatte ich natürlich stand
viel spielzeug oder so aber eigentlich
so lange ich mich erinnern kann hatte
ich immer ein starkes bedürfnis wenig zu
besitzen und ich weiß noch als es anfing
dass man musik digital haben kontert mp3
und soweit der erste der alle cds
gerippt hat und dann verkauft hat das
alles nur noch digital ist zum beispiel
und jetzt nicht bald auf weltreise und
war vor zwei wochen auf meine praxis
macht alles verkauft und alles was ich
besitze passt in einen rucksack und das
macht mich richtig glücklich mache ich
bestimmt auch der frei im kopf richtig
gern viele dinge a single speed ich habe
auch ein warum in lengerich und wie
speed das ist der 22 gänge des halte der
schwerkraft also warum schicken weniger
minimalistisch ob der hügel die fein
doch gibt in berlin richtig gelaufen und
warum macht ein minimalistisches fahrer
viel spaß
naja ich hab zur arbeit nicht so weit
war ein guter preis habe ich angst dass
getauft weil das so ein schwarzes
fahrrad das ist natürlich super geil da
hatte ich erst angst deswegen hatte ich
auch eine versicherung aber seit einem
jahr ist es hier also ich mag also so
wie ich kriegst du nur schwarz genau
aber das widerspricht er meine seele
glaube ich nehme aber minimal ich bin
ich wäre glaube ich gerne schafft aber
nicht also jetzt sagen wir mal
inneneinrichtungen als beispiel um
findet im endeffekt nicht weil man
irgendwie sachen hat aber hast du denn
alles was du sagst ist eigentlich
überflüssig
keine ahnung ich kleine zettel die man
aufhebt oder so sachen die man die wand
hängt von postkarten über irgendwas kann
man halt nicht einfach in kettwig
meisten kunden fällt hin
ist der mensch ist ja eher so dass er
das irgendwie letzten 100 jahre oder
auch schon länger der natur den krieg
erklärt hat und somit immer gerne alle
sammeln wollten männer wollen sammeln
leider und ja und wenn man ein bisschen
minimalistischer lebt aber auch ein
bisschen wärmer minimalistisch denken
kann man ja auch so zu sagen und ich
glaube dann können eine bessere welt
erschaffen
also ich bin sitze gerne viele klamotten
aber ich erkaufen secondhand diskus das
ist einfach mal mit gutem gewissen quasi
sich dinge leisten können aber eben
second fans also irgendwie was gutes für
die umwelt sag ich mal tun oder
nachhaltigkeit einfach um das man sich
einfach so wegschmeißen sondern möbel
kleidung
was hast du denn alles was maximal ist
also es ist natürlich mir wurde auch
schon erklärt ist natürlich schon ein
bisschen auch im luxus ist weil
natürlich wenn ich irgendwann in zwei
jahren zurückkomme und irgendwo 14 muss
ich mir die möbel und so weiter neu
kaufen
aber für mich total ein schönes gefühl
jetzt gerade alles was ich besitze in
ein rucksack stecken zu können
jetzt interessiert mich natürlich noch
wie ist das bei euch habt ihr gerne ganz
viele sachen in eurem leben oder
reduziert ihr immer und seit
minimalisten genauso wie ich schreibt
uns das in die kommentare
und was mich noch interessieren würde
wie war für euch die qualität von diesem
video
denn wir haben eine crew mitgemacht und
ist ganz minimalistisch gefilmten nur
mit einem smartphone bewaffnet und mit
einem kleinen sich mikrofon 30 jahren
einst hellsichtig gesteckt habe also ich
hoffe dass das ok für euch warm was wir
genau fixiert man benutzt haben schreibe
ich in die video beschreibung unten und
dort ist auch der link zu unserem pat
hearn wo ihr unterstützen könnt und dann
ganz viel zu das material zum deutsch
lernen bekommen
vielen dank fürs zuschauen wird weil